you know for all the talk about how Maga
trumpists are alpha big strong guys not
like Ron Des sanctimonious for all the
talk about them being alpha males there
was a very interesting confrontation of
sorts in the courtroom the day Trump was
arrested for the second time by all
accounts in the courtroom Jack Smith the
special prosecutor stared at Trump laser
eyes the entire arraignment whereas
Trump refused to even acknowledge the
guy sitting with his arms arms crossed
looking glumly straight ahead and of
course saying nothing his lawyer
entering his not guilty plea for him I
don't really get into all this Alpha
Beta stuff I think it's a false
dichotomy I think it's overly simplistic
I think it's unproductive but by the
standards of the people that love this
Alpha Beta stuff Trump hasn't exactly
been projecting Alpha energy lately and
Jack Smith certainly has